welcome to the five most amazing moves
of Anatole Karpov one of my favourite
players his style was said to be that of
a boa constrictor strangling his
opponent slowly but surely but when
asked what his style was Karpov famously
said I've got no style quite a class
answer I think remember to Like and
subscribe to this channel now and we're
gonna move over it's a five of his most
brilliant moves well in my eyes Karpov
was the most subtly brilliant chess
player ever his speciality was to stop
his opponents intentions
unlike towel who used to throw the
kitchen sink at his opponent Karpov
would refrain his opponents from doing
what they want to do and this position
here will wait to play is a very famous
example of that Karpov now plays are
really in Nice move what is the move
Karpov played and why more importantly
well he now goes Bishop to a7 and this
move may not seem that's sparkling and
that's what makes it that much more
attractive to me Karpov is simply
avoiding exchanging pieces on the a far
in the position before that black
clearly wants to exchange rooks get all
the heavy pieces rooks and queens off
the board which will ease his problems a
basic rule in chess is if you have more
space you want to avoid exchanges and
this move Bishop a7 just stops black
from doing what he wants to do and we
can see after a couple more
maneuvers white already has double power
on the 8th oh and he goes on to
outmaneuver his opponent who really
hasn't got many options in this position
a lovely subtle move which I think
really encapsulate s' compos style of
chess now before Carlsen came along
most people consider cop off the best
endgame player of all time maybe still
is who knows and this is his most famous
ending his opponent Gary Kasparov these
two special case had many F
encounter between them and in this
position Kasparov with the black pieces
took on h4
what did Karpov now play I think 99.999%
of any human being would capture this
pawn back the issue now as you can see
my lovely graphical things there is that
that white King cannot get into the
position and in the ending the King is
very important it can't come past any of
these free squares which are protected
by blacks pieces now I know this is
quite high level stuff but Karpov
amazingly played Knight - g2 giving up a
pawn in an ending a simply astonishing
idea this position helps him because his
pawns are on dart squares
meaning that Kasparov Bishop can never
attack them this is a very important
thing for the ending and we see the real
point very soon after pawn takes g3 I'll
let you discuss other matters in the
chat King takes g3
Karpov now has a way in for his king he
has no porn on h4 a weird position where
it's better not to have the poor and
after some maneuvering Karpov wins his
pawn back and slowly but surely we can
see now the white King has a way in
which it wouldn't have done had he
simply captured the porn back he goes on
to win maybe the most brilliant ending
of all time in fantastic style and just
this concept struck me as a young kid
and I hope also you guys can appreciate
the beauty of it on to example number
three well I know in my last video you
found the moves of Magnus Carlson's a
little bit too easy
so I'm putting you a challenge here and
this position was caught off against
Kenta Kamsky a famous American plan and
gotta Kamsky had got quite a dangerous
position with the Queen pointing down
here now what should black play and in
castling looks incredibly risky we
always want to get our King safe because
of Bishop takes h6 and the black King
gets ripped apart so what do we do here
will Karpov now come
of amazing idea can you see the idea and
at the time this was simply unseen king
to e7 there's a fine line between
stupidity and genius madness and genius
and this move sums up is this move
moving the King a beginners move or is
it a move of a genius well it's a move
of the genius Karpov wants to go g5 he
cannot play g5 in the original position
because of the pin on the H port the G
pawn can simply be captured Karpov
cannot take that bishop back but after
this wonderfully weird move now be
honest did you see this move I mean not
many humans would so for example had
Kamsky castled g5 is actually winning
material for black and a lovely idea if
you take this pawn now the rook on h8 is
simply defended brilliant stuff the game
continued with Kemp's key trying to play
aggressive with Knight e5 but now Karpov
simply captures that night and plays can
you see the move Queen a five chick
picking up the pawn on e5 car pulse one
a porn and it goes on to win the game
but again and a move which some of you
might think well that's not anything
special but for me brilliantly subtle
sums up composts amazing amazing power
on the chessboard now one of the most
amazing tactical sequences of all time
another rival of Karpov was courtly and
this is maybe one of the best games of
chess I've ever seen Karpov shows his
tactical flair here he's attacking on
the h-file and he comes up with a series
of devastating tactics now I'm gonna go
for it and quite quick but do pause and
just spend a bit of time on the tactics
and try to work out what happens white
to play what does white now do g5 this
is a discombobulating move meaning it is
a misdirection move it messes up blacks
pieces if the knight moves at all
we have Knight to f4 and we're going to
force our way to h7 so rook takes g5 was
played by quarterly and now comes the
second
and again pause if you want to rook d5
and an amazing move this rook now has to
be captured because the rook and Queen
have been separated
it can't be captured by the night
because a Queen takes h7 and Queen takes
8 h8 checkmate
so rook takes d5 is forced and now
Karpos idea Knight takes d5 trying to
get rid of the defender of h7 throwing
everything at the black king amazing
tactics rook to e8 trying to defend d7
and now Knight to e4 another piece comes
in bishop c6 and now another stunning
move the 3rd brilliant blow e5 and
another discombobulating move the actual
idea of this is to stop the black Queen
coming to the King side now what do I
mean by that well if you go for brute
force with Knight takes f6 there's
nothing really here for y we can take on
h7 but the black King escapes runs away
does a forest gump
run forest run so we can't do that one
and another idea here would be tonight
to h5 a beautiful idea threatening
multiple checkmates and also we have
Ruchi once but now the Queen shows its
power Queen to g5 check the Queen's are
exchanged and black can hang off this
brilliant move e5 has the points that if
pawn takes e5 we do the same combination
Knight takes f6 Knight to h5 but there's
no Queen to g5 amazing stuff and after a
5 well
Karpov went on to win in very brutal
fashion with rook to e1 coming Korchnoi
resigned this fast example was played
against English Grandmaster Vestal and
this was a case of combining positional
ideas which Karpov was great at with
tactical ideas it was also pretty good
at them so what would you play as white
hair in a position where maybe it
doesn't seem that you know weird or you
know tactical
well Bishop to f3 I have to mention
Bishop e4 was also interesting but this
move I really like quite a rare case of
Karpov which I'm sure a lot of you
haven't seen before now the point is
that bishops aiming for g4 so black has
to do something it seems like the bishop
is lost but after a couple of exchanges
Karpov has again like some of the other
examples distracted black away from some
of the squares he wants to defend mainly
g6 and now with Queen g6 check coming in
Karpov goes on to obliterate the black
king site and order protection around
this by swapping off all the pawns and
we can see after numerous checks he has
free pawns for the piece but the black
King is now so weak and of course messed
all cannot the fairness in the long run
eise is coming when the bishop also
joins in and a lovely example from
Karpov there of a weird move that
tactically works beautiful examples
there remember to like and subscribe to
this channel I really do hope you've
enjoyed this series leave your comments
below did you like these disciples or
did you prefer the Carlsen videos you
guys choose I want to hear some
discussion and also which of those
examples was your favorite and I'll
bring you more videos very soon
Aglio look at these videos
[Music]